[music]
Heat. [music] Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Hi Walter.
>> Did you try to beat me this time?
>> I had to try again. Yeah.
>> Okay. All right.
>> How are you doing?
>> Hey I feel like a gunslinger. Who's
going to draw first? [laughter]
>> Yes, we're in the Wild Wild West.
>> Yes, we are living in the Wild West now.
>> Definitely.
>> Okay,
>> so before we talk about the Wild West, I
just want to do some housekeeping again.
>> Some housekeeping. What have you What
have you done again? What have you left
undone?
>> I don't want to sweep anything under the
carpet, okay? But I want to just
enlighten people about some things
that's on the horizon with clash of
minds and also
helping us tools in helping us spread
the message. So the first thing is that
we have mentioned it before but we
seeing that we are in such
>> perilous times.
>> Thank you. It's I think it's necessary
that people invite and bring friends
along to the two outreaches that we'll
be having. The one in Oakland, New
Zealand, and the other one in Melbourne
in Australia. There's a smaller one, but
that one is basically already full, so
that won't help. But people can have a
look at the um details of where it is
and when it's going to uh take place.
And we in invite people people that have
not not heard the message before because
the time is now that we should spread
this. And another tool that we have
available to help is on our website. If
you go to our website there will under a
tab called resources we've got sharing
cards. So we want the people to use the
sharing cards. It's the three angels
messages that we've done in the WhatsApp
prof series. And um it takes people
directly to the video and then there's
more. But this is a cheap way for people
to partner with us. You can have a
church get together and say, "Okay, we
want to share
20,000 of these things because it's a
cheap way." There's also the more the
the um flash drives that we've we have
and we want people to go and have a look
at our website
>> and we we give it away so that people
can use it and as long as the Lord
enables us to do that we will do that.
>> That's it. The sharing cards is already
in print format. You can go there on the
website you see you download you give it
to the printers and they can print. So
please let's because you'll see after
we've done this. I think we the time is
now.
>> A loud cry needs a lot of voices.
>> And the loud cry. Exactly. And it has to
swell. This has to be it must be a
behold the bridegroom cometh.
>> Correct.
>> So let's pray and then we can get into
this.
Our heavenly father, we ask that you
please help us in this discussion
and also help all the viewers, all the
listeners and everybody that see this to
realize that we have to take this
message to the world now. Help us in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
Martin, we have been looking at the
news. We have been observing.
We have placed the filter,
the Bible and the testimony.
>> Yeah.
>> In between the world events and us so
that we can get a clearer picture of
what is going on in the world. And we
have decided to title this one second
beast rising.
Now, America for a long, long time
seemed to have been losing stature in
the world.
>> Mhm.
>> But the scriptures tell us that the
second beast of Revelation
>> Yeah.
>> which has to be lamblike. In other
words, it must have Protestant
principles in it.
And it speaks like a dragon must have
the power of the dragon.
So there must come a change when this
beast, this political entity that has
two horns, in other words, state craft
and church craft join together will
raise its voice and people will have to
take note whether they want to or not.
>> Yeah.
>> Whether they be enemies or whether they
be allies, it doesn't matter. you will
listen.
So the Bible tells us that it will come
to prominence and will raise its voice
and will rise above the others. You
know, there was in history
a little horn that grew from littleness
between 10 horns
>> and then the Bible says it became more
stout than the others
>> and it became prescriptives
and kings even in unison two kings
together would eventually lead the
pope's horse through the streets showing
the subservience
to this entity. [clears throat]
And here this prescriptive horn which
gets its power from the dragon.
>> Yes.
>> And the dragon of course is also
associated with Rome because the dragon
gives Rome its seat and its power and
great authority. It's actually the
proxy.
>> Yeah.
>> And here it is. And it is raising its
voice to speak like a dragon. Now
Martin,
if someone starts speaking to you like a
dragon, do you become a little bit
uppety?
>> Yeah, [laughter] I do.
>> What's the matter with you? You
rebellious or what's wrong with you?
>> Not rebellious, just um stubborn. I
don't know.
>> Stubborn. So, do you think it's possible
that when this second beast starts
speaking like a dragon that friend and
foe might start to grumble?
>> Yeah. Yeah, for sure. But eventually if
the pressure becomes so great, what do
you do?
>> Just capitulate.
>> Ah, capitulate.
Well, Martin, we're living in that time.
I
>> I'm working on a sermon
which I want to title here, not near
>> because not then.
>> It's here.
>> Yeah.
>> It's no longer near. The coming of the
Lord is near. No, it's here. You better
prepare. Yeah, I find you know what I
find fascinating. I know our theological
friends will always differ on this point
but uh I hope they they understand that
uh you know once you are settled in the
truth so that you cannot be moved.
[laughter]
It doesn't really matter what they think
on the issue.
But uh if you take the 10 virgins for
example,
>> the King James says the bridegroom
cometh.
The NV says he's here.
>> Oh.
>> Oh, I haven't seen that he's here, but
the NV seems to believe so. So anyway,
he's coming.
>> But uh his coming is near. So even if I
title here not near, it means the events
are here that will lead to his coming.
>> Yeah.
>> So that we don't follow what the NIV
says because uh that's a little bit of a
apostate thinking but nevertheless I
hope I haven't upset too many of our
dear friends. [snorts] So second beast
rising modern. What is this all about?
Well it's the endgame. It's the final
events that are taking place and whether
we like it or not, ready or not, here I
come.
Maybe we can just make it clear or
plain.
Just now there's somebody that's
watching the one of these episodes for
the first time. They have no clue what
we're talking about. Maybe we can just
tell them dragon equals Satan. Satan
sits behind the first beast who is Roman
Catholicism.
Second beast rising is the United States
of America who is doing the bidding on
behalf of the Catholic Church or the
Roman Catholic system. So correct
>> that's just to put it
>> and uh the dragon was also pagan Rome.
>> Yes.
>> And pagan Rome handed over the reigns to
papal Rome.
>> Yeah. and paple Rome incorporated
paganism into Christianity and make it
made it a paganized Christianity
>> which no longer is a Christianity
because it has removed Christ out of the
center there's no atonement the church
becomes your atonement so fascinating
story now Martin if you're going to
raise your voice
then you are placing pressure on many
nations. Now, those nations behind the
scene of course are part of the act.
>> So, what you see on the public display
is there for public consumption.
It's an exoteric doctrine. But the
esoteric doctrine has been established a
long time ago in the secret echelons of
secret societies
>> which are run by Jesuits and the like.
>> So modern hate speech laws
>> because if you cross this beast
if you say something contrary to it in
other words if you refuse to worship it.
Now the Bible is very clear that whose
dictates you follow is the one that you
elevate.
>> So in other words, if you follow and
worship the beast, that means you obey
the beast rather than the precepts of
God.
>> That's idolatry, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. That's an abomination, isn't it?
>> For sure.
So this beast will eventually be
prescriptive and any countervoice
will be dealt with in a very harsh way.
If you have another opinion, change it
[snorts]
>> or else I will come with my military and
blast you off the planet.
>> Is that is that how it works?
>> How it works? Ian state if you if they
say it's black and you see but it's
white then you change your mind to
black.
>> Exactly. Now who who said that the first
time round? Wasn't it the Jesuits?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> That's where we are.
>> Ignatius Lola.
>> If the church says that it's black and
you think it's white, you better change
your mind.
>> And do we see that?
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. Now, it's
fascinating how these hate speech laws
have crept into all nations, even those
that seem to be liberal.
>> And even well, even those that have a
Protestant
>> background or a communist background for
that matter, it doesn't matter. They're
all getting the same legislation.
And whether it is now in a
socialistleaning country like our own
country South Africa or whether it is in
uh Australia or whether it is in the
United States or whether it is in Europe
or whether it is in the UK,
>> it doesn't matter whether the government
is liberal or not. These laws are being
put in place. So, let's listen to these
hate speech laws that have now
been discussed in the House in in
Australia and what it entails.
>> The Albanese government's hate speech
laws have passed the House of
Representatives with support from the
Liberals and some national MPs. The bill
passed with 116 votes for and seven
votes against. The legislation states an
organization could be prohibited in
order to protect the Australian
community against social, economic,
psychological, and physical harm. But
some coalition MPs have questioned
elements of the hate group provision,
including what could constitute
psychological harm. Professor Joanna How
has raised these similar concerns and
joins me now. Joanna, what are the
dangers of this legislation?
Rita, in my 15 years as a legal
academic, I've never seen a piece of
legislation more terrifying and
threatening to Australia's democracy. On
the weekend, the Albanesei government
said that they were ditching the hate
speech elements of the law, the
antiilification provisions. But what we
found out today at 10:00 a.m. when it
was publicly released, is that they had
inserted some of the worst elements to
this bill into the definition section in
114. And so what this means is the bill
actually criminalizes hurt feelings. So
if someone in the target group has hurt
feelings, experiences fear as a result
of somebody else, another Australian
criticizing let's say immigration from
Islamic countries and that's a very
reasonable position to take given that
these Islamic countries are not
democratic. They do not allow freedom of
speech or freedom of religion.
Christians are persecuted in these
countries and in fact in these countries
women are severely oppressed. So if an
ordinary Australian criticizes that
under these new provisions, if an if a
Muslim member of the Australian
community feels fear, then that person
is a member of a hate group and they
could go to jail for 15 years. This bill
will lead to ordinary, innocent,
law-abiding Australians being sent to
jail, which is something that should
never happen in a western democracy.
Martin, if you are sitting in an
audience
and you are listening to a lecture on
the first beast of Revelation chapter 13
and uh the speaker explains why this
first beast is also the mother of
harlots
>> and has Babylon written on her forehead.
Would you be offended?
>> Yes. If I was in that system,
>> would you be psychologically disturbed?
>> Yes. I might feel threatened and it can
become serious.
>> So, how about cooling off for 15 years
in a prison?
>> Mhm.
>> It's interesting that somebody who rapes
and murders and pillagers gets left out
free on a bond or no bond.
and uh somebody who does something like
this or might be speaking the truth as a
matter of fact could be seriously
jeopardized. So these laws are in place,
right?
>> We've seen it in the UK where that he
was arrested or not even arrested,
sentenced for praying.
>> Yes. In your mind.
>> In your mind.
>> They don't even know what's going on in
the mind, but they assume what's going
on in the mind. So Martin, this is all
very fascinating. So this second beast
forces everyone.
You cannot force anyone without a law or
a proclamation which becomes law. Yeah.
>> All right. You cannot take over a
country without some legal precedent.
Their legal precedent now seems to be we
say so.
>> That's so true. I was just thinking now
you see this that happened now in
Australia.
A lot of conservative [snorts]
Christians will say this is
preposterous.
But then when it comes to them, they
would not mind laws being implemented to
safeguard them.
>> Correct? So it cuts both ways.
>> So this is another stirring for for that
pendulum that's already swung.
>> All right. Now Martin, if you want to be
a prescriptive nation,
>> can you then be [snorts] subservient to
a another
uh authoritarian organization?
>> No.
>> Because you're the boss, right?
>> Uh if you you know, he who pays the
piper calls the tune. Isn't that right?
>> Yeah. It's uh the golden rule is the man
with the gold makes the rules. All
right. So, he who pays the piper calls
the tune. Now, for years, America has
been saying that they have been paying
the piper.
>> Mhm.
>> And the piper is doing his own thing.
Whether that be NATO, whether that be
the United Nations, whether that be the
World Health Organization, it doesn't
really matter.
uh the piper
is going to play the tune
>> that the one who pays the piper is
asking, right? So the Epoch Times uh
told us here and this of course is
official news
that the US officially exits the World
Health Organization. Now the World
Health Organization
tried to force every nation
>> to be subject to their emergency rule in
case of a pandemic
>> and made nations sign documents many of
who actually signed those docins and
gave up their sovereignty in the
process.
So today, the United States withdrew
from the World Health Organization,
freeing itself from its constraints. As
President Donald Trump promised on his
first day in office, Secretary of State
Marco Rubio and Health and Human
Services Secretary Robert Kennedy Jr.
declared in a January 22 joint
statement. This action responds to the
WH whose failures during the CO 19
pandemic and seeks to rectify the harm
from those failures inflicted on the
American people. That's just a
precedent.
>> Yeah.
This is the latest move by an
administration that has been highly
skeptical of membership in a number of
global organizations
that in Trump's view and that of many
other conservatives comprise the
sovereignty of the United States and
operate counter to American interests.
We won't listen to you.
>> No,
>> we won't be collective. We'll be
prescriptive.
>> We'll be looking out for ourselves now.
>> Yes. In January 25, Trump withdrew the
United Nations from the Paris Accord,
which aims to limit global warming. And
on January 7, he withdrew in mass from
66 UN sponsored climate and social
justice organizations, amongst them the
UN Framework Convention on Climate
Change. So, it's not just the World
Health Organization. Nobody's going to
dictate to us. We're going to dictate to
you.
>> Yeah. Is that where we are? And
>> that's a power taking rising taking
over.
>> Is it the second beast rising?
>> For sure.
>> Does the Bible say it'll do that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
What people just a short time ago said
these are all conspiracy theories.
Conspiracy. Conspiracy. Conspiracy.
Right.
>> The whole time.
>> Fascinating.
But you know that we must remember that
what is the difference between a
conspiracy theorist and say the reality.
>> Well, you know that they say it's about
five months, isn't it?
>> Five six months. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And tapa tapas saucer said that uh
conspiracy theories are only believed by
those who studied them. [laughter]
>> All right. So, this Davos thing was very
fascinating
because it was totally controlled by one
man
>> for sure
>> and there were a couple of altercations
that took place there for the public eye
but subsequently there have been
capitulations.
>> So, Martin, who's the boss here? Let's
have a look.
>> For sure. So, never before has Davos
been so comprehensively hijacked by one
man.
Switzerland has been neutral ground in
the heart of Europe for more than 500
years. This week, Davos provided a safe
space for a full frontal assault on the
continent's economic and political model
that will be felt long after the
canopies are cleared.
The official Davos theme was a spirit of
dialogue, but when it came to Trump's
address was more a case of shut up and
listen.
>> Martin, is that the second beacon?
>> Does that sound like dragon talk?
>> This is dragon talk.
Commerce Secretary Howard Lutkin was
belligerent at every opportunity. We
have come with a clear message. He said
on a panel sat next to Chancellor Rachel
Reeves. Globalism is dead.
>> This is almost like Q.
[laughter]
>> You mustn't even mention that because
that's exactly what people are going to
go with.
>> Remember that. Do you remember that
people said that Donald Trump is Q
>> Q and this falls right in place. So the
devil is very clever.
>> He's very clever. He caters for the
other side very well.
>> He gives advanced notice. He creates
this euphoria, this hope. Then it looks
like nothing's going to happen. Then all
of a sudden it's there.
>> So it's about 5 months. The difference
between a conspiracy theory and reality.
>> Okay. Can the world change so rapidly?
I don't know if people realize that the
last year this world has been completely
swung around the pendulum from where it
was when the previous administration was
there and how the world was around where
is it now?
>> Yeah, it's about 5 months
>> if it is 5 months.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
It was a measure of US dominance of the
agenda that perhaps the highest powered
Davos lineup ever assembled was reduced
to a supporting cost.
Martin, this is interesting.
>> All these big mouths,
all these shoutters. Now I I'm just
interested in the symbolism.
>> Remember when Donald Trump went as an
official guest of the United Kingdom?
Yes.
>> When he was the very first president in
the history of those two nations
[snorts]
to be carted along in the royal
carriage, not in a black sedan, in a
royal carriage.
And there he came out, walked in front
with a king like droopy dog on a leash
walking behind him, doesn't it? And
there he stood before the royal god and
he saluted them while the king in his
usual fashion seems to have had his
hands tied behind his back. I don't know
how they ever get any work done when
they walk with their hands behind their
back all the time. I don't know. Maybe
they have eyes in the back of the head.
I don't know how this works. But the
emphasis was who's the king here? Of
course, it's it it even started with the
previous visit with the queen.
>> Yes.
>> He was also in front the whole time.
>> Yes. So, isn't it a a blatant just
display of who's in control? The same
that you mentioned now, the two kings
that had to carry the pope.
>> Yes.
>> Isn't it the same?
>> Interesting. Interesting. Anyway, so the
dominance was exerted by Trump and he
didn't he didn't obliquely say what he
wanted
[snorts]
>> spread out.
>> He he doesn't um play around with the
words. And like you mentioned earlier,
there's some murmurings from the other
ones, but they they just can't do
anything about it. They can just murmur.
>> They can just murmur and mutter, but
there's nothing that they can achieve.
And I'm wondering if the murmuring is
for public consumption
[snorts]
>> or whether the murmuring is just there
to give a token of resistance.
>> So yes, let's have a look at what the
Canadians had to say. And Prime Minister
Keane says US-led world order is
breaking. Let's see if it is so or not.
>> We understand that this rupture calls
for more than adaptation. It calls for
honesty about the world as it is. We are
taking the sign out of the window. We
know the old order is not coming back.
We shouldn't mourn it. Nostalgia is not
a strategy.
But we believe that from the fracture we
can build something bigger, better,
stronger, more just. This is the task of
the middle powers. The countries that
have the most to lose from a world of
fortresses and a most to gain from
genuine cooperation.
The powerful have their power.
But we have something too. The capacity
to stop pretending, to name reality, to
build our strength at home, and to act
together. That is Canada's path. We
choose it openly and confidently. and it
is a path wide open to any country
willing to take it with us. Thank you
very much.
>> Well, Martin, those were,
shall we say it, fighting words or were
they the last whimper?
>> I think it's the last whimper.
>> The last wimper.
>> Yeah. That it's a it's a call, but he
acknowledged the old world order is
gone. This is time for a new world
order.
>> Correct. Now, the United States told him
to wise up
>> or else.
And so he reached out to China
and Donald Trump said to him, "If you
make a deal with China, you get 100%
tariffs
and 75% or more of all trade goes
through the United States when it comes
to Canada. So the reality of the matter
is you better listen or else." And then
there's the question of this dome which
they call the golden dome.
>> Yeah.
>> Not an iron dome. No,
>> a golden dome for a golden age.
And Martin, just for interest sake, when
is the starting date for this golden
age?
>> It's the 4th of July, I believe, when
America turns 250 years old.
>> Oh. How many hundred years away from now
is that?
>> Oh,
>> about 5 months. [laughter]
>> Yes.
>> Isn't that about 5 months? [laughter]
So, between conspiracy and reality, we
have about five months, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And everything must be in place by then.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, how fast must you play your cards?
>> Immediately. And
>> if Canada is part of the North American
continent and Greenland belongs to this
enclave up there and this golden dome is
supposed to stretch across Greenland
because that's where the missiles fly
over.
>> Then you can't very well blank out
Canada. No.
>> So Canada must be included in the Golden
Dome. Who finances this golden dome?
>> Well, obviously the United States will
fund it.
>> Oh, so Donald Trump is saying these guys
are benefiting with no contribution.
>> Sorry, pal. And he consistently calls
him governor.
[laughter]
>> Yes, the whole time.
>> He He doesn't call him prime minister.
He says the governor. And he called
Trudeau, who is now flirting with
Hollywood ladies, uh he called him
governor as well.
>> So what is he saying?
>> You're part of the United States as a
state.
>> And all of this rhetoric that is going
on
is fascinating to me. It's interesting
that Alberta
seems to have said it has more in common
with the United States.
>> Yes, I remember there was a big thing
they wanted to join the United States if
at one stage. So like a secession game.
So really behind the scenes,
>> if you take the maps that were produced
by the Club of Rome many years ago,
>> then Greenland, Canada and the United
States were one economic block.
>> Yeah.
>> So this has been planned for a long
time. What we are seeing now is just uh
exoteric rumbling.
>> The reality of the matter is Canada
doesn't have a choice.
So when Donald Trump said, "If you make
a deal with China, 100% tariffs," what
did uh the prime minister who just said
he was going to sail his own boat, what
did he say?
>> Uh okay.
>> Yes, sir. [laughter]
>> Didn't he?
>> No, we won't do it. Sorry, we won't do
it. Okay. Yes, sir. The reality is this
is all a game for a already
predetermined strategy.
>> Yeah, for sure.
Did he get Greenland according to him
now?
>> To him? Yes. He
>> And did he have to pay for it?
>> No.
>> So Martin,
do you Has this happened to you before
that you got a piece of real estate that
is so massive that uh you know it's just
amazing? Some say it's the size of the
African continent, which of course I
don't believe, but nevertheless uh for
nothing.
No, I've never received.
>> Whether the people on on it don't want
it or want it is irrelevant or whether
the the governing country Denmark wants
it or not, it's irrelevant.
>> No, I think the last time this happened
was when Rome was in charge.
>> Uhhuh. By the way, who drew the maps
>> in the Middle Ages?
>> The popes.
>> The Pope drew the maps, right? And his
lackey.
Did they create problems with their
maps?
>> Of [clears throat] course. Did they
care?
>> No.
>> No. [laughter]
>> It sounds the same.
>> The second beast is doing the bidding of
the first beast and acting just like it.
>> It's exactly the same.
>> So, Donald Trump humiliates the World
Economic Forum elites during brutal
Davos takedown. Let's have a look at
this.
>> Donald Trump has been on fire at the
World Economic Forum in Davos,
demolishing the elites who he says are
taking advantage of the United States. I
realized in that conversation that the
United States is keeping the whole world
afloat. Many places I could give you
six, seven places just in the people in
this little area. I know every one of
them. They're sort of they're looking
down. They don't want to see me and they
don't want to stare me in the eyes. But
they're taking advantage of everybody
took advantage of the United States.
Without us,
it's not Switzerland anymore. Without
us, it's not any of the countries that
are represented here and we want to work
with the countries. We want to work with
them. We're not looking to destroy them.
>> And Trump wasn't done. The president
then humiliated the president of France,
Emanuel Maccron.
>> He said, "Here's the story, Emanuel. The
answer is you're going to do it. You're
going to do it fast. And if you don't,
I'm putting a 25% tariff on everything
that you sell into the United States and
a 100% tariff on your wines and
champagnes.
And that's about 10 times more than what
I'm requesting.
And you're going to do it. I don't want
to go public with it, but you may make
me do that. No, no, Donald. I will do
it. I will do it.
It took me on average 3 minutes a
country.
Saying the same thing, you will do it.
They all said, no, no, no, I will not do
it. You're asking me to double the cost
of prescription. I said, "That's right,
because you've been screwing us
for
30 years."
>> He then went on to call out the
disastrous energy policy of the UK and
Europe.
>> There are windmills all over Europe.
There are windmills all over the place
and they are losers.
One thing I've noticed is that the more
windmills a country has, the more money
that country loses and the worse that
country is doing. But despite calling
them out, the Davos guests still gave
Donald Trump a standing ovation.
We are in Davos at the World Economic
Forum and the Trump administration and
myself, we are here to make a very clear
point. Globalization
has failed the [music] West and the
United States of America. It's a failed
policy. [music] It is what the we has
stood for which is export
offshore farshore find the cheapest
labor in the world and the world is a
better place for it. The fact is it has
left America behind. It has left the
American workers behind. And what we are
here to say is that America first is a
different model. one that we encourage
other countries to consider, which is
that our workers come first. We can have
policies that impact our workers.
Sovereignty is your borders. You're
entitled to have borders. You shouldn't
offshore your medicine. You shouldn't
offshore your semiconductors. You
shouldn't offshore your entire
industrial base and have it be hollowed
out beneath you. [music]
You should not be dependent for that
which is fundamental to your sovereignty
on any other nation. And if you're going
to be dependent on someone, it darn well
better be your best allies.
We do believe that we need more growth.
We need more stability in this world.
But we do prefer respect to bullies. We
do prefer science to plotism. And we do
prefer rule of law to brutality. You're
welcome in Europe. You are more than
welcome to France.
>> All right. So, it seems that Macron gave
a whimper and a matter.
>> Yeah. And then it's
>> and then there's nothing.
>> He's going to capitulate. He has no
choice.
>> That's a that's a capitulation there. Um
we don't like bullies, but okay. You're
still welcome.
>> You're still the boss. [laughter]
All right. So, Martin, what really
happened in Venezuela? Right. That's an
interesting question.
>> Was it only did it only um the whole
effect of taking him and arresting
Maduro? Did it happen overnight? Was the
planning of that only a overnight thing?
>> Was it a flash in the pan thing? Was it
a a show of force? Nobody's doing
anything about it. They all accepted it.
Uh even the big nations, Russia, China,
all of them are murmuring. Murmuring
murmuring, muttering. But Martin this is
very interesting. If we look at the the
economist
uh it is always very predictive if I can
say that and almost uh uncanningly
accurate
>> every time. You've we've dealt with
economists many times. remember the
attack in Israel, how they showed it
ahead of time and all of these things.
>> And then they have this rather
uh chaotic picture here on their cover
which seems to be an indication of the
globe
and uh what's happening on it. And you
see rockets and you see military and you
see archers, you know, triumphant
archers
and you see communications and you see
pictures depicting Chinese attitudes,
Russian attitudes
and then you have this fist over here
with handcuffs on it.
>> Yeah.
>> So if we enlarge that, Martin, this is
roughly what it looks like up there,
right? Yeah.
>> And then you have Maduro over there
giving the same hand signal. Well, not
with the handcuffs on at this stage over
here.
>> Not yet.
>> Not yet. But uh this is basically what's
going to happen.
>> Yeah. That the obviously the economist
this was brought out long before all of
this happened
>> and it's centering around the 250 as
well there.
>> Now Venezuela has the the largest oil
reserves in the world.
And uh you know if you go to Daniel
chapter 11 it's pretty clear that that
king of the north has power over all the
gold and the economic resources of the
world.
>> That means he must control them right
>> and he just took it. And power is uh
necessary.
And if you want this power in order to
dictate then you must have the resources
otherwise you can't force force people
to play economic games
>> buying and selling.
>> All right.
So Martin was Donald Trump just uh
taking the initiative by saying well if
we control this oil then we have a lot
of economic power at our disposal. or
did it come earlier?
>> I think it definitely came earlier.
>> All right. Now, this regime
has been tolerated for a very very long
time,
>> but it has been at cross purposes with
the Vatican.
>> Yeah,
>> that's very interesting. Right.
>> That's the interesting part.
>> And it actually at one stage begged the
pope for assistance
>> actually twice
>> and it was refused.
>> Yeah. And it's interesting that Pope
Francis is the one who said this regime
must go.
>> Yeah.
>> So who did the command come from? Did it
come from the first beast or did it come
from the second beast?
>> I hope people can listen to what you
just asked.
>> All right.
>> Focus people. Where did the command come
from
>> to go and take out
this system? [snorts]
But it's not only that system because
Martin look at this. This is
this fist which stands for basically
communistically inclined socialism.
Right.
>> Yes.
>> Which apparently is tolerated but not
really toler tolerated in the United
States if you look at the story of the
mayor of New York for example now and
all of those issues. But it's going to
go. So the next nation after this one
would be Cuba that has the same
situation. Now Cuba was totally
dependent on Venezuela for its oil
>> and now it's getting nothing.
>> Yeah.
>> So Donald Trump says we don't have to do
anything about Cuba. It's going to
collapse all by itself.
>> So we're just waiting to pick up the
pieces. But we will run Venezuela.
>> Yeah.
>> We will run it. And I don't care what
you say or what you do. In one blow, he
has removed this massive flow of oil
>> which was going to the enemies so-called
whether they really are enemies. They're
all Jesuit controlled but for public
consumption
they are now really in a bind because a
lot of the oil of China comes from
Venezuela etc etc and Iran is a player.
>> Yeah. And along with this, he also
confiscated I don't know if it was only
one uh oil vessel from the Russ from
Russia.
>> No, a number of them now. I think is the
third one. And
>> and they using this oil beautifully
there in the United States at this.
>> Yes. And these drug cartels, they're
they're so stupid. They still keep going
out with their boats to keep providing
entertainment as to how they are being
obliterated. Right. So Martin, this is a
very interesting game. But the economist
said that uh this system of governance
is going to be handcuffed.
That means somebody must be the
policeman.
>> Yeah.
>> In order to enforce that and thereby
also take all the resources.
So the papacy
ordered that the system must go not only
Pope Francis but Pope Leo as well.
So is this following the dictates of the
first beast
>> completely?
>> Completely. So this agenda will not be
stopped.
So let's look at this video as to what
happened when the pope made this
decision so that people can see that
there is a chain of command.
>> Yeah. It's like a man behind the mosque.
>> Correct.
Well, the latest now on the Venezuelan
crisis and President Nicholas Maduro of
Venezuela has appealed to Pope Francis
to help initiate a dialogue in order to
resolve the political crisis. In an
interview to Italy's Sky TG24, Maduro
said that he sent a letter to the Pope
affirming that he is a Christian.
Aroma
Cristiano.
the letter sent to uh Mr. Maduro, Seenor
Maduro in response to his one uh which
is dated 7 of February 2019
of Pope Francis in my view is de facto a
request of surrender to Maduro because
the pope wants to be a mediator but at
his conditions and he says Maduro with a
very soft diplomatic jargon typical of
the Vatican that in the past actually
Maduro uh didn't respect and comply with
the pledges taken in uh past agreements.
So uh beyond this soft language the pope
is quite tough in saying yes I can be a
mediator but at my conditions I think
Maduro after this letter is more
isolated because I think that the pope
was accused to be too much ambiguous
about the regime. This letter explains
that the pope is not ambiguous. He's
just trying to avoid a bloodshed. But
the judgment about this regime is quite
tough.
>> And then as to Greenland and to Iran,
Trump's threats stretch far and wide
since his Venezuela strike. Doesn't stop
there.
Since the seizure of Venezuelan
President Nicholas Madura by the US
forces at the weekend, US President
Donald Trump and members of his
administration have issued warnings to
several other governments, including
those of Colombia, Cuba, Mexico, Iran,
Greenland,
a so-called self-governing territory of
Denmark. Trump said Sunday, "We are in
the business of having countries around
us that are viable and successful and
where the oil is allowed to freely come
out as we want."
>> Yes.
>> Let's add that, right? American
dominance in the Western Hemisphere will
never be questioned again, Trump said.
Martin,
this church state union,
it's largely being played out in
Christian countries.
>> In other words, the Western Hemisphere.
>> But that's exactly what the Bible says
would happen.
>> And anybody who tries to interfere with
that is going to get
>> a dragon talk.
>> Yeah.
>> So, he's he's just done it, right? He's
just going to do it. And like we said,
they're muttering and murmuring and
whatever,
>> but there's another agenda behind it.
>> And we must understand that because this
beast is prescriptive. It's going to
make laws and it's going to affect
buying and selling. That means economic
warfare
>> and it will draw to the church state.
>> Do you remember the king of the north?
>> Yes.
>> He came with many ships. [snorts]
>> That's the economy, right? But he also
came with chariots.
>> Yeah. War.
>> So he's using his military. And that
economist picture showed all of those
tanks and all of those issues. Our
economic might and our military might
will dictate on behalf of another
entity. We have to get there. So let's
just see what they have to say about
Venezuela.
>> Well, what the president said is true.
The United States of America is running
Venezuela. By definition, that's true.
Jake, we live in a law or sorry, we live
in a world in which you can you can talk
all you want about international
nicities and everything else, but we
live in a world in the real world, Jake,
that is governed by
strength, that is governed by force,
that is governed by power. These are the
iron laws of the world since the
beginning of time. But in terms of
day-to-day operations in Venezuela, that
is President Acting President Rodriguez,
right? It's not some sort of American
emissary.
>> No, what I'm saying is we and we'll
we'll keep going here, Jake. So, I want
to say what I'm saying and you'll follow
up. But what I'm saying is just one
level above that, which is that by
definition, we are in charge.
>> How is it governed, Martin?
>> By force.
>> Force
>> and iron. Iron.
>> This is iron law.
>> Iron. Now, where does the iron come
from?
>> Oh,
>> isn't that Roman law?
>> Yes.
>> Aren't those the legs of iron?
>> Oh, Martin, this is this is so
interesting. And this is this is the
reality.
>> You remember this same guy at Charlie
Kirk's memorial?
He said, "You have unleashed a beast."
>> Yes.
>> The talk, his rhetoric is amazing.
>> It's It's second beast rising. It's he's
got biblical um talk the whole time. Um
the the things that he said
>> so church and state are dictating this
issue. This is what happened in the
middle ages.
Battle lines were drawn, maps were
redrawn, things changed. Is there any
difference now? If they if they changed
the borders and drew the maps in the
Middle Ages,
>> they're doing it now.
>> They're doing it now. the rewriting
redrawing the map of who's part of the
United States.
>> And so who controls it? Trump says his
own morality is the only limit on
presidential power. He's not going to
listen to any European leader. Whether
that's stroma or whether that is Macron
or whether that is the German
leadership, he doesn't care. and whether
it's even biblical morality. No, it's ah
>> but this is fascinating because he
constantly brings in the religious
element and he constantly says we will
not tolerate any negative statements
against the Roman Catholic system.
>> So Martin this is fascinating. So, Trump
is briefed on opinions for striking Iran
as protests continue.
>> And according to the New York Times,
citing multiple US officials familiar
with the matter, President Trump has
been briefed on options for military
strikes inside Iran as he considers
following through on threats to respond
to Iran's crackdown on protesters.
It comes just days after we got a
glimpse into President Trump's world
view in an interview with the New York
Times.
>> Do you see any checks on your power on
the world stage? Is there anything that
could stop you if you wanted to?
>> Yeah, there's one thing. My own
morality,
my own mind. It's the only thing that
can stop and that's very good.
>> I don't need international law. I'm not
looking to hurt people.
We are going to do something on
Greenland whether they like it or not.
We're not going to have Russia or China
occupy Greenland and that's what they're
going to do if we don't. So, we're going
to be doing something with Greenland
either the nice way or the more
difficult.
>> So, Martin, this is all playing towards
the golden era of the United States.
>> Now, the golden age,
>> the golden age. Uh, you know, there was
a time in history that history turned
the dark ages.
>> Mhm.
>> And the papacy keeps referring to it as
the golden age,
>> is it? That's excellent because they
they're not the only ones that referring
to it. And we'll be seeing a little bit
of a
>> Do they want the golden age back?
>> Yeah. Who why is it the golden age for
them? Because they were ruling.
>> They were in control. Everybody did
their bidding. So we're going to go back
to that. Trump says construction of the
triumphal arch is to begin in two
months. Now that was as you see there at
the end of January last year. So that's
a month ago. He said in an interview on
Wednesday that construction of his long
tease triumphant arch is expected to
begin sometime in the next two months.
That would put the start date ahead of
July the 4th, 2026
as the White House ramps up preparation
for the nation's 250th anniversary next
year. It hasn't started yet. It starts
sometime in the next two months. It'll
be great. Everyone loves it, Trump told
Politico
when reached by phone from Mara Lago.
They love the ballroom too, but they
love the triumphal arch. Now, they say
it's schooled on uh the one in Paris,
>> but there are many voices that say
actually they are all schooled on
Constantine's triumphant arch.
>> So, is he playing the emperor role?
>> How many times have he has he been
called?
>> Cyrus and Constantine
>> and Constantine.
>> Yes. especially by the Catholics.
>> Yes. So he's playing this role.
>> Now what did Constantine do? He merged
paganism and Christianity. What else did
he do, Mark?
>> He brought in a Sunday law.
>> He brought in a Sunday law,
a mark of the beast.
>> Mhm.
>> Fascinating.
So, you know, this has all been
conspiracy theory in the past, but now
it is conspiracy reality.
First American pope to welcome Hollywood
stars to the Vatican for rare holy year
ordinance. Pablo is seeking to bridge
the gap between the Vatican and
Hollywood. By the way, Hollywood, which
is of course the witch's staff,
>> is that a tool of the Vatican? Isn't it
like you always say it's Jesuit theater?
>> It's Jesuit theater.
>> All of them are trained in in in
theatrics in any case.
>> Correct. Yes. All the popes too. Some of
the film industry's biggest names will
have an exclusive audience with the
leader of the Catholic Church Saturday.
In this Jubilee year, by the way, is it
a real Jubilee or is it a fake Catholic
Jubilee?
>> Fake. fake has expressed his desire to
deepen dialogue with the world of cinema
and in particular with actors and
directors. The Vatican said in a
statement that's just briefing them.
>> The plan has been there if you
especially if you watch Little Light
Studios this has been coming a long
time. It's just probably going to kick
up a notch after this get together. Now
this person is part of a system that the
Bible calls anti-ristos
antichrist.
>> And that means to be in the place of
Christ. Now in this so-called Jubilee,
was there an open door that he shut?
>> Yes. For a whole year
>> in the sanctuary, was there a door that
was opened and that was shut?
>> Yes.
>> Is he is he playing a role? Exactly. His
timeline is somewhat different, but
that's that's his game. He changed times
and laws, remember?
>> So, he's playing an open and shut door.
What happened in a Jubilee, Martin?
>> Things reverted back to the old system.
>> No, it should be. Yeah.
>> What was it like in the middle ages?
>> They were ruling.
>> And uh if it goes back to the old
system, what happens then? Then if you
don't want to fit in with that system,
you will be um sorted out.
>> You'll be sorted out. So the Vatican
added that the pope wants to explore how
creativity
can tr contribute to the mission of the
church and the promotion of human
values.
These are of course values for the
common good and not values that have
been uh prescribed in the scriptures.
Right.
>> And what was the mission of the church
in the middle ages? Correct.
>> You had to be part of them. Otherwise,
>> there was no salvation outside of the
system. None whatsoever. So here we have
this jubilee having ended in this time
period when there's a transition from a
Francis pope to a Leo pope
>> who is also the pope of Rum Novarum
and also the pope that has to implement
it which means that Sunday law must be
on his agenda because that's part of Rum
Novarum. He's finishing the job that the
previous Leo started.
>> So, Pope Leo the 13th was the first
siege.
>> 1888.
>> Yes. And Pope Leo I 14th will be the
second siege.
>> Yes. It's the same power. It's Rome.
>> It's Rome. And did they use the trade
unions?
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> Okay. So, what does the National
Catholic Register have to say? Why 2026
will be the year of Leo. Fascinating,
huh?
While 2025 will forever be remembered as
the year of the Catholic Church got its
first American pope, 2026 is likely to
be the year that he begins to fully make
his mark.
Do you think he's going to implement the
mark of the beast via his lackey, his
proxy?
>> I think the table is set. Okay. Most
notably, the US bishop's plan to
consecrate the nation to the sacred
heart of Jesus ahead of the 250th
anniversary of the American funding. By
the way, this is a totally pagan idea,
>> the sacred heart issue. It's also the
sacred heart of Mary. He's not going
quite so far. is he's uh consecrating it
to the heart of Jesus. It's basically
consecrating it to obedience to the
Catholic Church.
>> I think yes because I think you can say
if I'm correct in thinking so that
they've distanced them a little bit from
this marology
but that is to become more um acceptable
by the Protestant.
>> Correct. because in in his other
homalies
>> he's making it quite clear that he's
subject to Mary
>> 100%.
>> All right. So what does that mean? Even
while overall levels of religiosity
continue to fall, stories of young
people drawn especially to Catholicism
and its more traditional devotions and
liturggical expressions have seized both
secular and Catholic attention. The
recognition of an American saint would
be a fitting highlight for a year said
to be marked by both the consecration of
the country in its 250th anniversary
year and the full-fledged reign of the
first American pope. Martin that that is
a mouthful.
>> That statement at the end for instance
puts him above King Trump.
>> Correct. Because the spiritual sword is
higher than the secular sword. Now an
American saint, it would be very good
Martin if uh this saint were an IT man,
right?
>> Yeah. [laughter]
So maybe you can get an indulgence if
you follow some tweets again. So Martin,
this is a very interesting statement.
So, I'm getting very interested in this
250th
anniversary
>> and Donald Trump has made it quite clear
that this is the starting point of a new
era, a golden age for America.
>> Do you think it is coincidence that he's
the president at this stage?
>> No, it was planned that way.
>> Must be.
>> It was planned that way. So the 4th of
July actually we can take that a little
bit further because the actual signing
took place a little bit later but round
about this day end of July
we can expect some amazing things with a
consecration
to basically the papacy.
>> Yeah that's what they say here
full-fledged reign of the first American
pope.
>> The first American pope. So that's not
chance either. The devil is playing a
very interesting game here. The table is
set. So if it's a full-fledged rain,
then he must make his mark.
>> Yes.
>> Now his mark according to their own
definition
is the change from Sabbath to Sunday
because it affirms the authority of this
power over and above the scriptures.
>> Yeah. That's putting him firmly as
antichrist. That is the most blasphemous
statement ever.
>> Interesting as well, the young people
are more traditional
Catholics.
>> Yes.
>> Vatic prevatican 2
>> because they've never really been
exposed to the scripture. They've been
exposed to exactly what it says there.
Traditions and uh
>> liturgy
>> liturgies.
Tradition and liturgy doesn't cut it in
vain. They worship me
>> teaching for doctrine the commandments
of men
>> and Martin it's important that the
church becomes prominent
>> and that action is taken against any
irreverent action towards the church.
>> So I'm wondering whether these things
are planned when they storm churches for
example. Well, do you think the woke the
emergence dur from 2020 on till now was
planned or?
>> Of course, it was planned.
>> Then obviously all these other things
must also fall in place.
>> Wasn't Biden a very faithful Roman
Catholic?
>> Well, let's have a look at this video.
>> All these comfortable white people who
are living lavish, COMFORTABLE LIVES
WHILE CHILDREN ARE DRAGGED INTO
CONCENTRATION CAMPS. YOU'RE LIVING REAL
LIFE NICE lives with your lattes doing
absolutely nothing for your Latino and
Somali brothers and sisters. You You
come here TO A MAN WEARING A SUIT IS A
PREACHER. DID JESUS wear a suit? Did
Jesus PROFIT OFF THE WORDS? NO. JESUS
WOULD DIE WITHIN. You do not touch me.
Touch me again and see what happens.
>> Hey, you can't leave.
>> You are A FAKE CHRISTIAN. WHY ARE YOU
NOT STANDING WITH YOUR SOMALIAN LATINO
COMMUNITIES? WHY DO I NOT SEE YOU OUT AT
WHIPPLE EVERY DAY PROTESTING THIS ATTACK
ON HUMANITY? Where are you? And you
should know that that's not the last
clip like that you're going to see, not
just tonight, but in the future, because
that's the animating spirit behind what
you're watching.
>> Taka Coulson, was he part of the
Heritage Foundation?
>> Yes, for years. Very.
>> Did he make speeches at the Heritage
Foundation?
>> He worked for them. He That's where he
started off.
>> Oh,
>> interesting. If you look at the
video that is there, look at the at the
wall behind him.
>> I know what's behind him there.
>> It's a picture of Fatima on it and it's
got even Catholic and Islam on it.
>> Everything is there. So, Martin, the
time has come when America is rising
and taking on the role prescribed for it
in the scriptures. Yeah.
>> And it is doing it on behalf of the
first beast.
>> And the first beast has decided that the
250th celebration is the time when Leo,
the first American pope, will make his
mark.
Oh, this is fascinating.
>> You cannot even you can't make this up.
That's what they always say. You cannot
make this up. It is amazing.
>> He's going to make his mark. And now is
the time to bring people back to God, to
put the church back in control,
and to save America from all this
wokeness and evil and uh all of these
issues.
So saving America by saving the family.
But this comes from the January the 6
and it's from the Heritage Foundation.
Just does that also sound like a
familiar phrase that the papacy usually
show the family. Oh, this is point A in
all the rhetoric. Francis was famous for
it in all his encyclicals. And it's all
associated with synchronized free time
on a Sabbath,
>> namely Sunday,
>> although that is the first day of the
week. So saving America by saving the
family, a foundation for the next 250th
year. Martin, what's the starting point
here again?
>> The 4th of July.
>> The 4th of July, the golden age.
>> Yeah.
>> When the papacy will make its mark and
Pope Leo will begin his year of reign,
his his year of first reign. Because you
remember the Babylonian king had an
ascension year
>> and that's exactly what [laughter]
Wow. And he first had to complete and
finish what Francis started. Now he can
do his thing.
>> That's right. That was Francis's agenda.
Francis's agenda, let's put it quite
bluntly, was to make the pendulum swing
so far to the left so that it can swing
completely to the right in the era of
Publio. I absolutely absolutely it must
be
>> because it's happening.
>> Yes,
>> we did see that we swing there. It's
swung already and now all that Leo has
to do and it will be interesting to see
his first encyclical.
>> Yes. And he was playing role king of the
south but he was sitting at the same
table.
>> He would just and Francis who was the
first Jesuit pope he just did his job
perfectly.
>> And did he appoint this person? to the
cardinals.
>> He appointed him. [clears throat]
>> All right. So, let's save the family for
the next 250 years when the actual year
of reign begins.
Well, it began in 2026.
So on July the 4th, 2026, Americans will
remember how the founding fathers won
their freedom and established ordered
liberty through a system of limited
government, federalism, and the rule of
law. In understanding their crowning
achievement, Americans must recognize
that the founding fathers were quite
literally fathers.
54 of the 56 signers of the Declaration
of Independence married and had a total
of 337 children amongst them, an average
of six each.
family. Martin, the task of the authors
of this special report is to propose
ways to remove the many obstacles
blocking the formation of healthy
families, to make marriage and family
life easier and to restore family to the
center of American life in rhetoric and
in reality.
>> This is a paper agenda.
>> Look at this wording.
It must be with the rule of law to bring
back American life in rhetoric and
reality.
>> Yes, we must speak according to this
word and we must act according to this
word.
>> You better accept it, Martin.
>> So, Martin, what is their first
demand in order to achieve this? Shall
we read on?
>> Yeah. Well, they've put together now a
document again. The we must just remind
the people that these are the authors
[snorts] or the initiators of the
project 2025 document.
>> Correct. Most of which has already been
implemented except for this portion.
>> Yeah.
So how do they propose saving it? Let's
read page 38 of their document. Support
for a uniform day of rest as zoning laws
allow a community to determine where one
can operate certain businesses. Blue
laws reflect the local judgments as to
when one can operate certain businesses.
In the case of McGoan versus Maryland
1961, the Supreme Court held by an 8 to1
vote that Sunday closing laws that
include the purpose of providing a
uniform day of rest are constitutional
and can accommodate the fact that the
majority of the people who take a day of
rest for religious reasons do so on
Sundays.
So they bring in a legal precedent.
Yeah.
Massachusetts, for example, requires
that every employer of labor engaged in
carrying on any manufacturing,
mechanical, or mercantile establishment
or workshop shall allow every person at
least 24 consecutive hours of rest in
every seven consecutive days.
Day of rest laws limited commercial
activity are usually found in less
densely populated counties, although
restrictions on alcohol sales are more
widespread. Though greatly diminished,
blue laws persist in some form in close
to 28 states. These places serve as a
sort of legal reservoir. Once their day
of rest laws are abolished, they are
very hard to restore. a uniform day of
rest. Again, they always emphasize this
uniform day of rest, synchronized day of
rest, which means it can only be Sunday
because you want to restore the family.
Remember
>> that's it and that's why they mentioned
it there and in the project 2025 they
said it will default to Sunday.
>> So if two parents are working and one
has a day of rest on Wednesday and the
other one, let's say on Sunday, that's
not synchronized rest. the family is
disrupted has to be synchronized.
So this uniform day of rest that limits
commercial activity can provide temporal
boundaries that help communities to set
aside time for religious observances,
family gatherings, outdoor activities
and rest. Now Martin just think of the
inconsistency.
Just think of the inconsistency
because they're allowed to watch sport
for example
>> and sit in stadiums which are basically
religious uh
>> temples
and those players down there haven't
they disrupted their families by being
on that field rather than with their
families. They don't they don't take
that into consideration. Right.
>> Maybe the people that has to work at the
stadium
>> as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
So a stable base of re research shows
that these practices correlate with
better mental health, stronger social
bonds, more stable family structures.
These things have been argued not only
in the United States, in the Heritage
Foundation, but in the Sunday Alliance,
in Europe, wherever you are, these
issues are on the table.
>> And the Bible actually states the same
that it is good for your mental health.
It is good for social bonds and family
structures and all of that if you adhere
to the biblical
>> correct
>> Sabbath. Correct. Because then there
wouldn't be an infidel in the world
because nobody would forget that they
were created.
With the advent of ondemand delivery,
shopping can be shifted easily and
conveniently to other days of the week.
By restoring a common rhythm of rest and
reflection, community rest laws could
help to reverse the trend towards
spiritual homelessness and foster the
social habits necessary for communities
to adhere and flourish.
Despite today's ondemand culture, the US
Postal Service does not deliver regular
mail on Sundays. Most organized youth
sports avoid Sunday competition and most
banks are closed on Sundays.
The ever popular Chickfila
chain closes its restaurants on Sundays
for the benefit of its workers and their
families. where new planned communities
or transitioning communities form, they
should consider adding rest days as part
of their matter plans for balanced and
thriving
community life. So basically they're
saying we want Sunday laws.
>> They don't mention here other days.
>> No,
>> they've they've narrowed it down now.
This is what we need. In the project
2025, they still acknowledge that other
people might have another day like
Saturday, but they said the default is
Sunday. So now they've discarded the
other days. They are with the default.
It's interesting that Charlie Kirk,
[clears throat]
who actually kept the Saturday as the
Sabbath,
>> has now through his wife, [snorts] who
is now in charge, moved that goldpost to
Sunday.
>> Yeah. They the even in his book there is
a Sabbath. Sabbath. It was not this
Sabbath.
>> Whether he wrote that specifically or
not is not for us to say. But was he on
the translation committee of the NIV
Bible that uh or all these modern
translations that tried to distort that
in Colossians?
>> Yeah.
>> I don't think so. He was a bit young for
that. I'm I'm joking. Of course.
>> Of course. I'm just being a little bit
facicious.
>> It is interesting that um this was like
a catapult this whole Charlie Kirk.
>> Yes.
>> In actually catapulting this Sunday,
this rest day into your face.
>> Now let's get serious modern. When this
happens,
then this mark that the Bible talks
about has become a reality, right?
And it is a choice between obeying
traditions and commandments of men or
the commandments of God. That's the
choice.
>> That's it.
>> So it's a choice of authority. Whose
authority are you subject to? The
authority of God which plainly tells you
the seventh day. The number seven is
God's number. And he didn't come to
change the law. Not one jot or tit came
out of place after Jesus was here. He
made that quite clear. So this is a
question of authority. You see, it's
hard for people to understand that this
is what it's all about.
>> It's about authority.
>> So they can show it's for the family. It
will look so biblical. All of this will
be there and it will be preached. And
then you going to ask, but why make such
a big deal only about the Sabbath?
>> Yes, it's a question of authority.
>> Why is it? Isn't it? Because it's what
it's all about.
>> That's what it's all about. Now, Martin,
the 7th Day Adventist Church has been
warning about this for more than 160
years.
And within this church, we have liberal
organizations
that mock the more conservatives one and
called their rhetoric conspiracy
theories and all kinds of things. Some
of them have called us numerous times
conspiracy theorists. And I believe
maybe even on the project 2025 that
we've been dealing with, but it seems
like somewhere a wasp flew in and maybe
stung
>> some of them.
>> Some of them. Well, I'm glad that it's
happening. So, I'm not knocking it at
all.
>> So, Adventist Today, which is a very
liberal think tank,
>> says that the Heritage Foundation wants
Sunday laws for all faith. No
exceptions.
Heritage Foundation reports calls for
human form Sunday laws and they are
speaking up against it. It's amazing
that when project 2025 was there, they
were
>> silent as [snorts] the grave. But
something woke them up. I hope everybody
else wakes up as well. The Heritage
Foundation proposes Sunday day of rest.
Adventist Church issues warning.
Is this the second siege, Martin?
>> I believe it is.
>> The first siege came when Alonso T.
Jones gave that remarkable speech in
which prevented the first siege, the
first Sunday laws coming to the United
States
>> under Pope Leo the 13th
>> under Pope Leo I 13th. And now we have
another Leo rising and he wants to set
his mark upon the United States of
America. Fascinating. and not only the
United States of America but the whole
world
>> because everybody has to accept the mark
of the beast. Right.
>> I'm also very gratified to see that the
North American Division has also issued
a statement Sunday rest proposal raises
troubling religious liberty concerns.
And so there are people that are raising
their voices. It's the voice of alarm.
It's the beginning of the loud cry.
>> Amen. And that's why when we started, we
ask people, help us to make this
visible to people.
>> Now, how serious is this? You know what?
This is not just a flash in the pan. For
the last months, the labor unions have
been preparing people behind the scenes.
For four Sundays in a row, the US
Department of Labor has proclaimed the
following.
Happy Sunday, America.
Happy Sunday. Enjoy your Sundays. Why
are they sending these things out,
Martin? The Department of Labor.
>> Of course, because they will be the ones
that bring about a time such as never
was.
>> All right. Now, under which papacy? Now,
this is so fascinating.
>> Yes. Under which papacy did the labor
unions actually start?
>> Leo the 13th.
>> And which papacy said that they are
going to complete that work?
>> Leo the 14th. Rum Novar.
>> And here the labor unions are asking
the people to rest on Sunday. Happy
Sunday America. Enjoy your Sunday.
>> This is on their Facebook page. You can
go and have a look. It's their Facebook
page. Yes. So, four Sundays in a row
they are sending this out and the
Heritage Foundation comes with this
modern here. Not near.
>> No,
>> it's here.
>> It's here.
>> We've been waiting for this for 160
years plus.
So, Martin, let's make it quite clear.
What is the clash of minds?
I wonder which organization calls
themselves Clash of Minds, Martin, it's
such a presumptuous name.
Which [snorts] system is going to clash
with which system? Which two mindsets
are going to clash?
Hopefully the one has a biblical basis,
>> a true biblical one.
>> A true biblical basis and the other one
has a traditionalist basis in vain. also
Christian.
>> Also Christian. And does the one
consider the other Christian?
>> No. Let me make it quite plain. I don't
consider even though I came out of that
system that Roman Catholicism is a
Christian denomination.
>> Exactly.
because they have replaced Jesus and
have instituted a system where you are
saved through the system rather than
through the atonement.
>> Now they don't consider
those that keep the commandments of God
and hold to the testimony as Christians.
So let's look at their mindset set. It's
also interesting that they say that the
dark ages was actually a golden age.
>> Now, we must remember this is not a
Roman Catholic speaking. This is a
Protestant, a Christian nationalist
speaking.
>> Yes.
>> But they've got the same
>> mindset
>> mindset as you we mentioned this ear
just earlier. You mentioned that the
Catholic Church see the dark ages as a
globe. So, let's see. You know behind
every prominent leader there stands a
Calaldian a Jesuit.
So in these Protestant organizations
there are also Calaldians Jesuits
controlling the mindsets. Listen to what
this man has to say about this golden
age.
The majority right now would say, "Well,
the dark ages were terrible, you know,
and they're burning witches, you know,
and um everybody is oppressed by
Christianity and by, you know, the
clergy and and and it was just this
horrible horrible time." Um whereas uh
at that time the the majority would
disagree. The majority uh during those
centuries would say, "No, Chrysom is
great. Uh we love Christ. We love his
church. Uh we're making incredible
advancements. Uh we've pushed back on
the darkness and on de driven literal
demonic spirits out of um northern
European tribes and you know places and
the Americas and you know all this kind
of stuff and making incredible progress
where um incredible discoveries and
charting new maps and um and innovation
and inventions and um so I'm of the
persuasion that I think the the whole
idea of the dark ages is a scop. I think
that the dark ages was actually a golden
age and that the great enlightenment is
actually the the dark spell that has
come over the west and that if anything
we're in the dark ages now. Here's five
criteria for voting. Number one, uh
America should be a Christian nation.
I'm a Christian nationalist and so yes,
I would require a public profession of
faith that you're a Christian in order
to vote. So my first requirement before
getting into anything else is faith.
It's religion. You should be a
Christian. Well, what kind of Christian,
Joel? A a creedle, historic creed.
Christian, you should publicly affirm.
You should have to publicly affirm the
Nyian creed.
The the the apostles creed. Well, what
about Catholics? Could they vote? Yes.
Well, what about Eastern Orthodox? Yes.
What about Baptists and Anglicans and
Episcopalians and and Presbyterians?
Yes. What about Mormons? No. It's a
cult. No,
no. They don't believe that Jesus is the
creator. They believe that he is the
first created. They believe he's the
first created, but not creator. They're
non-trinitarian. No, of course they
can't vote. They're not Christian.
Jehovah's Witness, what about them?
Nope, they're not Christian. Seventh Day
Adventists, nope, they're not Christian.
It is a cult. Okay, but what about
Muslims?
No way. What about Jews? No way. Hindus.
No way. Atheists. No way. Well, what
about white European descendants who
worship Thor? No way. Christian. That's
first. Martin.
The man has left me speechless.
We're not Christian.
Does he give a reason why we're not
Christian?
>> Yes. He says we're a cult.
>> Ah. Now, a cult Martin, isn't that a
group of people
that adhere to a non-biblical source for
their revelation?
>> Yes. And they put that above
>> the scriptures.
>> So, Martin, isn't the Catholic Church
the biggest cult on the earth?
>> It must be because the catechism is more
important, isn't it?
>> That's the tradition by which it is. But
they will say, "Ah, but the spirit of
prophecy is part of Adventism. The
spirit of prophecy has never been above
the Bible. The Bible is the standard."
The issue is he said that you have to
have a creed.
>> Exactly. And Adventism says we have no
creed other than the Bible.
>> The Bible and the Bible alone is the one
that determines doctrine. The spirit of
prophecy is in total support of the
scripture and doesn't supersede it.
>> No.
>> So we don't qualify as a cult. They
qualify as a cult.
>> The Roman Catholic system for sure. Now
>> do the Protestants have creeds?
>> Of course. That's what he just said
there. You have to lay down the Nessian
creed, the apostles creed. So
>> So creeds.
>> So we have no creed other than the
Bible.
>> That's it.
>> They have a creed. Now in those creeds
have they adopted for example Roman
Catholic creeds?
>> Yes.
>> Do they have confirmation?
>> Do they have communion? Do they have the
sacraments?
>> Yeah.
>> Where in the Bible do you read about
anything like that? Nowhere. Right. So
they have creeds and we don't have a
creed. So according to him we don't
qualify
according to us. Well, according to me,
at least I hope to according to you,
too.
>> Sure.
>> They don't qualify because they put
their creed above the scriptures.
>> Yeah.
>> Martin, what does the Bible say about
those that put their creeds and their
traditions above the scriptures? In
>> vain, they worship me.
>> Well, now, here's a fascinating
statement in the great controversy. I
think we should unpack this a little
bit. What do you think?
>> [laughter]
>> We might have to stir again, but let's
go.
>> Shall we be unapologetically
unapologetic?
>> Yes. [laughter]
>> A noise shall come even to the ends of
the earth.
For the Lord has a controversy with the
nations. He will plead with all flesh.
He will give them that are wicked to the
sword. Jeremiah 25:31.
Now listen carefully.
For 6,000 years, the great controversy
has been in progress. Now, I want to
make it quite clear that this is not in
the context of her time.
>> This is in the context of the final
events taking place.
>> Yeah. This is in the end of the great
controversy book.
>> So, when these things happen, it's 6,000
years.
If you read the Septuagant, you're in
all kinds of knots here.
But fortunately, if you read the
received text, you're fine or the
Maseretic text.
For 6,000 years, the great controversy
has been in progress. The Son of God and
his heavenly messengers have been in
conflict with the power of evil one to
warn, enlighten, and save the children
of men. Now, all have made their
decision. So when are the 6,000 years
up?
>> When all have made their decision.
>> Ah so it's in the context of the 6,000
year period that culminates in this
final decision. The final decision
according to the scripture is between
the mark of the beast and the faith of
Jesus.
>> Right?
>> That's it.
>> Okay.
>> Those are the two. There's no other.
>> There's no other.
The wicked have fully united with Satan
in his warfare against God. The time has
come for God to vindicate the authority
of his downtrodden law. Now the
controversy is not alone with Satan,
but with men.
>> The Lord has a controversy with the
nations. This is quoting scripture.
>> Yeah.
>> He will give them that are wicked to the
sword. So, the 6,000 years are over when
this final decision comes to a head.
>> Before that, the second beast must rise.
>> Yeah.
>> The image of the beast must be formed
before
probation closes.
>> The wound must completely be healed.
>> It must completely be healed. So, the
wound must be healed and the 6,000 years
come to an end. Now, we did a
presentation
as to when the 6,000 years probably end
of, of course, we must be totally wrong
on that one [clears throat]
because I just read, Martin, that they
found cave drawings
>> that are now 68,000 years old.
>> Oh,
>> yes.
>> Okay.
>> Maybe 68 and a half years old. or maybe
68 and a half and 1 month and 2 and 1/2
hours. I don't know exactly, but that's
how old they are. Martin, the Bible says
6,000 years.
>> Mhm. This great cosmic week theory was
believed by the pioneers, but it wasn't
only believed by the pioneers of this
church. It was believed by the church
fathers. They all wrote about it this
great week of time.
It was believed by the apostles. It was
believed by the pioneers of this church.
It is encased in the spirit of prophecy.
But we're not allowed to speak about it
above a whisper. It's not time setting.
>> It's just a question of how old is the
earth.
>> Now, when this comes to fruitions, then
6,000 years are over.
Now, I don't want to give a date again
because then everybody gets into a tis,
but we know roughly when these 6,000
years are over. So, let's give a a
couple of them. Was it at the birth of
Christ? Well, then they would have been
over already. Was it at the baptism of
Christ? Well, that's when Daniel's
prophecies predict the Messiah's reign
begins when he starts.
Was it at the cross of Jesus? Was it
that the stoning of Steven? When was it?
>> So there are people that will choose
certain ones. We made our position quite
clear in number eight of what's up prof.
>> So Martin uh my question is if these
events are now coming to fruition and
this choice will be made what is the
next step?
>> Implementation of the Sunday law.
>> Okay.
>> Then goes probation. Sooner or later,
probation must close. But before
probation can close, there must be a
shaking.
>> Yeah.
>> And there must be a loud cry.
>> Yes.
>> And many of those that are outside, come
out of her, my people,
>> will join the ranks of God's people who
keep the commandments and have the faith
of Jesus Christ.
>> So, a very short period of time. And we
don't know how long that time is.
>> No.
>> So we're not time setting.
>> We have no idea what follows after that.
What comes after the loud cry?
Close of probation.
>> That's it. Decisions have been made.
>> What comes after the close of probation?
>> The plagues.
>> What happens in the final plague?
>> Everything is wiped out.
>> And Jesus comes.
>> Jesus comes
>> and he takes his people away. Yeah.
>> How long are those last plagues?
Over what time period? We don't
>> Well, one day it can't be a literal day.
>> So, some of the pioneers actually
believed like Haskell for example
believed that he could apply the day
year principle there and that it would
be one year. If I read uh the spirit of
prophecy, then it seems to me that the
time frame is more or less what it was
in the time of Morai. So that would make
it a shorter period than that. Let's say
about 9 months. But let's say in that
period
there is a falling of plagues. What the
precise length of that is we do not
know. But it probably won't exceed a
year or else nothing would survive.
Martin,
are we at the point where probation
could soon close?
>> I think so. We're looking at the signs.
We're looking at the biblical
explanation of what's happening in the
world.
Let's put our faith in God.
Is God going to adhere to a time? You
know, I read an article by one of our
pioneers
on this issue and he said when God
created the angels,
then he set a day of judgment
>> because angels were also under probation
to make a decision for or against
obedience to God's requirements.
Eventually, it came to war in heaven and
some of them were thrown out and a day
of judgment was mentioned which was
preserved or reserved for the devil and
his angels.
>> Ahu. It doesn't say reserved for
mankind.
>> But that day of judgment is fixed. So
before God created any intelligent
beings, he set the day of judgment.
And then this issue played out and the
angels fell a portion of them and then
mankind fell
and six days were given for creation.
six days which is a model of the days of
time for a day a thousand years because
it's very clear that the Sabbath the
rest is going to be a thousand years the
millennium
>> the millennium
>> so the other periods could also be
thousandyear periods and according to
the spirit of prophecy Christ came at
4,000
so that means that we must be at the
end.
So here, not near. What does that mean
for you and me?
>> That means that right now, not tomorrow,
not the day after, I must make my things
right with God. And then we have to get
this message out to the world.
>> Must you be settled in the truth that
you cannot be moved?
>> Yeah.
Must you have listened to the voice of
the Holy Spirit who has prompted you to
change your life and to come into
harmony with God's way and to see it
God's way
and implement it? Is it enough to have a
theory of the truth?
>> No, it must be an implementation, a
total transformation.
>> There must be a total transformation.
Someone uh looking at this timeline, how
much time is there for this
transformation?
>> Not a lot.
>> Now, if you continue to sleep until you
hear, "Hey, the bridegroom's coming."
>> Do you have time for this
transformation?
>> Then you can be part of the virgins that
don't have any oil.
>> Okay. Now, when the scripture says the
decree goes out,
>> that means the close of probation
decree. Let him who is unjust be unjust
still. If he that is unholy be unholy
still. Let he who is holy be holy still.
Uh the only holiness that we can
claim lay claim to is an imputed and
imparted righteousness from Christ. That
means we must have allowed Christ to
change our lives to bring it into
harmony with his. Right.
>> Yeah.
So after the close of probation, can
anybody make a a decision to reverse
whatever situation they are in?
>> No.
>> Too late, right?
>> Yeah. But I also believe that even
though you would have had a chance, you
would they won't do it anymore.
>> No, cuz they are fixed. They are so
settled in their ways that they cannot
be moved. In the same way, God's people
must be so settled in the truth that
they cannot be moved. That means they
must be sealed.
>> That's it.
And
don't be stubborn.
>> I I cannot appeal to people enough that
this is no more a a question of
conjecture. This is no longer a
conspiracy. This is a reality. I believe
we are just before the final events. And
may God help us to make right decisions.
>> Amen.
>> Let's pray.
>> Heavenly Father,
for a long time this message has been
preached.
For a long time it has been ridiculed.
And to see a world view
where seventh day Adventists that exalt
Jesus to the throne of God, that see him
as the God man that came not only as
their creator but as their redeemer. to
accept the atonement of Jesus Christ, to
accept obedience to his law should be
excluded from the term Christianity
because they refuse to accept the
sperious creed and hold to the scripture
and the scripture alone is a sign from
heaven that the final conflict has
actually
come to fruition.
Give us wisdom. Help people to
understand the issue and help them to
make decisions that lead to eternal life
rather than eternal oblivion is my
prayer in Jesus' name. Amen.
>> Amen.
[music]
Heat.